this morning we take a look at the City
of Stockton in California as part of our
ongoing series American Voices
we're exploring how issues facing the
u.s. are playing out at the local level
in 2012
Stockton filed for bankruptcy and was
one of Forbes his most miserable cities
in America Stockton is now ranked the
second most fiscally healthy city in the
state but nearly one in four people live
below the poverty line in 2016 Michael
Tubbs was elected mayor at the age of 26
he is the youngest mayor of a city with
more than 100,000 people and is
Stockton's first african-american mayor
mayor Tubbs is addressing his towns
poverty with an innovative and
controversial program to give some
Stockton residents $500 a month to fight
economic hardship he's with us now mayor
Tubbs good morning good morning thanks
so much for having me I know your city
has struggled for years with income
inequality and poverty why universal
basic income
what's interesting because idea is
almost as old as the Republic so Thomas
Paine was calling for this in the grain
revolution dr. King before he passed
even Richard Nixon
the idea is that especially in
California one in two Californians can't
afford one $40 emergency my people are
working harder and harder only to fall
further further behind so a group called
the economic security project was
looking for a city in a pilot with
philanthropic funding no taxpayer
dollars and given the challenges of
Stockton but also given the resilience
and the brilliance of our residents I
thought it would be a good fit for us
you know kind of the first stop of the
criticism is give people money and they
won't work it doesn't incentivize them
it's just a welfare program but what's
interesting the research says something
different so there was a study done the
Eastern Band of the Cherokee Native
Americans I'd found four thousand to six
thousand dollars a year did good things
for the folks that educational
attainment rose drug use went down and
there was no labor market impact so
we're hoping to see something similar in
Stockton you've got a wide span of
supporters everyone from Bernie Sanders
to Elon Musk to Richard Branson support
this initiative and it's beginning in
August right of this year ideally in
August we just had a program director
and so the next couple months she'll be
working with the community so the
community input figure out criteria and
selection work out the kinks and
hopefully by the time school starts
we're starting well what are some of the
criteria that that it will have if you
get the basic income what are some of
the things you put in the program to
avoid some of the criticisms
the ideas that it be as universal as
possible meaning you win me so someone
who's make $70,000 could get it someone
who makes seven thousand dollars would
be equally eligible to qualify I mean in
a second Tennant will be that it'll be
no strings attached that we trust that
people are smart in resilience and would
make the best decision for them their
families with the money understanding
that everyone's not going to do it right
I guess but that isn't happiness status
quo anyway it's a penalty if you don't
do it right you know it's 500 dollars no
strings attached the idea is to have a
conversation about kind of economic
system of this country but also
highlight stories are when suddenly a
smart 500 can do whether it's the
difference between the mother who's
above now pay for child care and get
back in the workforce or entrepreneur
who's able to work on their startup
ideas or artist it's really highlighting
the stories they've been a new face to
the conversation around poverty in the
country Stockton is not far from Silicon
Valley why hasn't it reaps some of the
benefits and that huge amount of wealth
that's in that area where we are working
on it I think part of it has been
oftentimes we've been so tunnel vision
and focus just just on stock because
we're close we're also a world away on
our diversity our average income the
educational attainment so we're working
on all those things just this month we
announced a 20 million dollar
scholarship program so now that every
kid in our school district could go to
school essentially tuition free yeah
really had quite the economic recovery
from 2012 right when you just graduated
from college let me ask you because the
president's really been touting a lot of
his initiatives over the past year have
you seen that come to fruition in your
city have you seen your citizens reap
the benefits of what the president said
he's been doing over the past year well
we're hoping to reap the benefits from
the opportunities on program but
honestly a lot of the time has been
spent kind of quelling fears especially
around immigration so for the past year
we've been having a conversation about
values because Stockland is one third
floor board meaning the majority of our
population are either immigrants or
children of immigrants so when we're
talking about taking people for families
and deporting people were doing raids it
causes a huge ripple effect in the
community so we've been filling those
effects and letting people know then
Stockton we're a city of immigrants
we're proud of our diversity and they're
and we're safe here what has been sorry
the reaction from the Attorney General
jeff Sessions to threatened to punish
Stockton for your immigration policy
which was interesting because it
mayor talked about jails and the city
doesn't operate jails the county does so
we sent the letter back nicely and said
you know we're a city of immigrants
we're not gonna stop the taint or frisk
someone just based on immigration status
and if you wouldn't talk about the jails
you got to talk about to the sheriff
which is a different office from the
City of Stockton and did they are you in
conversation with them or is it just a
one way thing from the Department of
Justice we respond when needed tell me
about those ripple effects you were
talking about in terms of the what the
president is saying to this immigrant
community and it causes a lot of fear so
then we see children are going to school
for example or we see folks are
reporting crimes for example or people
not engaging with government in a way
and for that to happen in Stockton it's
bad because again majority of our of our
population are either foreign-born or
their parents are meaning that they're
all that is our community and if they're
not part of it then we're not able to
have the civic life we need let me ask
about another thing you're trying which
is with paying what some people are
calling cash for criminals which is a
program that pays a stipend to young
people who were involved in crime yes a
program called advanced piece idea has
seven criteria the idea is that in most
urban cities a small percentage of
people commit the most violent crimes I
mean while the cops will still do their
things and gels will still exist but
while they're still in our community I
think we owe it to invest in them
I'm sorry --is that they're part of a
fellowship and if they meet certain
criterion after six months they're
eligible for a stipend based off work so
it goes to the ethos of having to earn
your keep but we're just making sure
we're doing what we can to invest in
everyone in our community especially
those who are the most marginalized and
oftentimes create the most harms is it
correct
I read that only seventeen point four
percent of Stockton residents have
bachelor's degrees that's absolutely
correct and we're working incredibly
hard to change that so I mentioned the
scholarship program we just launched to
make it so that young people see
colleges attainable in that's something
we're really focused on in the city
because that's going to be their
long-term key to our transformation you
are quite a success story yourself 26
year old mayor a Stanford grad what made
you decide that you were ready to be
mayor of a city like sucked I spent four
years on city council representing
everything I grew up in in those four
years working with the community we're
able to do things that sounds small but
we're huge we close down problem liquor
stores we open health clinics we got the
whole can
you organize around the South Stockton
promise on the reinvent stop stalking
idea and people would come to the
council meeting saying you only care
about self stop that you only care about
South Stockton at first I was like well
I'm doing my job but then I have was
listening and I said well maybe they're
saying the rest of the city could use
the same level of leadership so then I
decided to run for Mara 2016 1 and spend
a nice long fun and often hard journey
everything brought a lot of innovative
ideas and we'll be following them for
sure mara thank you so much for joining
us